the most common crowd work mistake is  also the easiest to avoid todd berry is  so good at crowd work he has created his  own crowd work tour and comedy special  this clip is a master at work follow me  on twitter sir  of course that's the way you talk to me  could have said yes could have said no  he said of course  did you notice what he did he repeated  what the audience members said most  crowd work is done with someone on the  first few rows so everyone behind there  is left out of the conversation hearing  just a one-sided discussion thank you  i do amazing work thank you holy [ __ ]  this guy's [ __ ] unbelievable  he's going no thank you  the audience member's response not only  lets the whole crowd in on the joke but  also gives you time to think of a  response or even to just repeat it and  make a joke out of it shout out to brent  hess for requesting todd berry and i  hope this clip helps you avoid